the movie opens up in a lab where a rat
accidentally gets trapped in a cage
there it sniffs something and tries to
investigate when suddenly an unseen
Force rips it to pieces and consumes it
oh my God was that morbius meanwhile our
main character a scientist named
Sebastian is working on a chemical
formula on his computer but sadly his
simulation fails however after he peeks
at his beautiful neighbor he gets an
idea and reworks the formula making it
stable this time excited about the
solution he calls his co-worker Linda
and showcases his successful chemical
formula to her he even jokingly mentions
that they should get ready to receive
the Nobel Prize soon no that's going to
Auto after hanging up the call Linda
wakes up another man Matthew who also
works at the same lab the two appear to
be having an affair but Linda wants to
keep it a secret until the right time in
the next scene they get dressed and
reach the heavily guarded lab where
Sebastian uses his fingerprint and
password to enter inside they observe
animals that are invisible and can only
be seen through thermal imaging Matthew
interacts with a gorilla named Isabelle
which clearly appears to be agitated he
puts on his thermal goggles and attempts
to calm her down but ends up getting
bitten
following this Isabelle runs out of the
cage and creates havoc in the office
Sebastian and Matthew chased the
Invisible Gorilla throughout the lab
until they Corner her without wasting
any time Sebastian then tranquilizes her
but Sarah a vet objects to injecting the
untested serum however Sebastian brushes
off for concerns and rudely says that
she was hired for her expertise and not
her animal loving nature later Linda
prepares the serum that Sebastian
developed to make the invisible animals
visible again she then carefully injects
it into Isabelle's veins to see remarks
temporarily making her partially visible
but soon she goes into cardiac arrest
this causes Panic among all the
employees prompting them to use a
defibrillator on the gorilla fortunately
the plan works and Isabel comes back to
life the serum also stabilizes her
heartbeat making her fully visible
everyone in the lab erupts in joy and
Sarah is optimistic about Isabelle's
recovery after this they all go to a
restaurant to celebrate the following
week Sebastian presents their research
findings to a pentagon committee he says
that his team has successfully created a
formula which can make animals go
invisible however when Dr Kramer
inquires if they have developed a
reversion Sebastian lies claiming they
haven't figured it out yet this
obviously surprises Linda and Matthew
but they decide to remain silent for now
Dr Kramer then warns the team that if
they don't find the reversion soon they
will be replaced outside Linda asks
Sebastian the reason for lying and he
explains that if they reported their
progress the Pentagon would take over
the project completely he also Reveals
His idea to proceed with unauthorized
human trials to change the world and
potentially win the Nobel Prize This
concerns Matthew as he is fearful about
the consequences but Sebastian dismisses
his concerns later Sebastian informs his
team about the risky plan and Sarah
can't believe that such a dangerous
experiment got the committee approval
however Sebastian is determined to
proceed no matter what happens he then
declares that he will be the prime
subject for the experiment on the day of
the procedure Matthew tries to talk
Sebastian out of it but he mocks him
soon the team prepares Sebastian for the
experiment connecting him to an IV and
restraining him on the bed he admits
feeling tense with an elevated heart
rate as they irradiate the serum and
bring it over to Sebastian he insists on
injecting it himself to avoid blaming
others if something goes wrong after the
injection everyone anxiously watches for
results but there's no immediate change
in Sebastian's body but after a few
minutes he suddenly begins convulsing as
patches of invisibility appear on his
skin he expresses more pain than
expected and is a vital signs become
erratic indicating he's on the verge of
a seizure or maybe he's about to blow
with the continuing invisibility process
the remaining members prepare the
defibrillator for any emergencies
Matthew advises them to wait as they see
Sebastian stabilizing during the
transformation finally he becomes
completely invisible and a technician
named Frank calls the moment when the
phase shift occurs although Matthew
reassures them that Sebastian is
physically okay he is unconscious due to
the traumatic experience 17 hours later
Sebastian wakes up in pain and asks
Linda and Matthew to turn off the lights
as he is facing problems opening his
eyes however they explain that he can't
close his transparent eyelets Sebastian
then goes to the mirror and then returns
to the lab area where he startles
everyone they use thermal goggles to see
him and Matthew and Linda take him back
to his room setting up observation
monitors later Sarah falls asleep during
her shift and Sebastian sneaks into the
observation room to touch her that
didn't take long when she wakes up he
pretends to be in bed Sarah shares her
concerns with Linda who is unsure if it
really happened later Matthew wants to
talk to Sebastian about it but Sarah
advises against it during medical
checkups Sebastian continues to make
Sarah uncomfortable the team discusses
their worries about Sebastian's Behavior
as an invisible man even at night during
Linda's shift Sebastian messes with her
and makes inappropriate advances which
she rejects the next day the team
attempts to use the serum to face
Sebastian Back Body starts choking and
his organs appear and disappear
erratically they manage to stabilize him
but decide to keep his condition a
secret from the committee since he will
remain invisible for a while they create
a synthetic mask for him with holes for
his eyes and mouth Sebastian sees
himself in the mirror with the mask on
and gets surprised then he goes to join
Slipknot in the next scene Linda and
Matthew try to work on the reversion
serum formula from home but struggle to
figure it out Matthew admits he's not as
brilliant as Sebastian who could jump to
the right conclusion easily except of
course when it comes to sexual
harassment as the days go by Sebastian
becomes physically and physiologically
sick due to the continuous testings he
argues with Matthew about it but Linda
Comforts him feeling unsatisfied with
their efforts Sebastian decides to leave
the lab that night he informs his
colleague Carter but the latter tries to
stop him due to the rules however
Sebastian insists he can change the
rules because he is the one in charge he
then leaves the compound promising to
return in a couple of hours after this
Carter calls Linda to inform her about
Sebastian's departure meanwhile
Sebastian evades the police guard
outside the compound and drives off at a
traffic light he frightens a couple of
kids nearby next Sebastian goes back to
his apartment to collect some of his
belongings while he is at it he notices
his beautiful neighbor undressing in her
apartment realizing that he is
completely invisible an evil idea
strikes Sebastian's mind he removes his
mask and sneaks inside the neighbor's
apartment then he stares at her for a
while before inappropriately assaulting
her moments later Linda arrives at
Sebastian's apartment finds his mask and
realizes he has been there at the lab
the team prepares to find him discussing
the need to keep his condition a secret
from the outside world unexpectedly
Sebastian returns to the lab claiming he
only went to his apartment to get some
things Linda confronts him about what
she saw and Matthew questions his
decision to go out in public in response
Sebastian asserts his authority as the
project a leader and defends his actions
when he starts getting aggressive Linda
threatens to report him to the committee
if he leaves the lab again the following
day Matthew he thinks he has found a
solution and explains it to the team but
the simulation breaks down at 95 percent
this makes Sebastian very angry and he
storms out of the room later he tampers
with the security camera to make it seem
like he's in the lab he then goes to
Linda's apartment to spy on her but at
the same time Matthew arrives there
Sebastian is livid by what he sees so he
smashes the window Linda immediately
suspects that it is Sebastian so she
calls the lab to check on the cameras
however the rigged cameras show that he
is still in his bed meanwhile a deranged
Sebastian arrives at the lab and
brutally kills a dog why the next day
when Sarah enters the animal Department
to give them food she discovers the dead
dog and confronts Sebastian however he
casually denies any involvement the
security camera also shows him in bed
all night but Linda is certain that
Sebastian tampered with it she then
calls everyone to the lab and they
collectively decide to inform their
seniors about the situation unbeknownst
to them Sebastian is standing outside
eavesdropping on their plan in the next
scene Linda and Matthew arrive at their
senior Dr Kramer's house and reveal
everything to him the latter gets
enraged at the unauthorized experiments
but agrees to call the necessary people
to take action unbeknownst to them an
invisible Sebastian is observing
everything from outside after Linda and
Matthew leave Dr Kramer tries to make
the call but the phone line appears to
be down then out of nowhere Sebastian
appears drags creamer to the pool and
mercilessly drowns him in the water the
next day when Linda returns to the lab
Sebastian startles her saying it will be
a busy day Matthew reveals that he came
back at 3am and has been wandering
through the labs since then shortly
after the two get to know that Kramer
mysteriously drowned in his pool last
night shocked Linda tries to call the
General but the line drops and they
discover that they have no connection to
the outside world soon the group
realizes that Sebastian has removed
their access leaving them trapped in the
lab while searching for him they are
horrified to find a technician's dead
body outside the door as the group
starts panicking an invisible Sebastian
confronts them and says I enjoy this
power now but Linda is having none of it
so she Powers up the motion detectors
and spots Sebastian on the monitor
Matthew and Carter go to find him while
the rest keep watch however Sebastian
surprises them and Matthew accidentally
shoots a pipe making Sebastian visible
due to the vapor an intense brawl that
ensues which ends with poor Carter
getting fatally injured in the aftermath
Sebastian escapes and locks Matthew in
the tunnel he remains on Matthew's side
making himself Invisible by raising the
temperature and rendering the goggles
useless the goggles they do nothing
Linda goes out to help Matthew and the
rest try to get Carter after a while
Sarah and Frank find Carter but
unfortunately he has lost a lot of blood
from his wounds Sarah goes to get blood
for a transfusion while Frank stays with
Carter unfortunately as she is
retrieving the blood packets from the
lab she hears Sebastian entering the
room acting quickly she pours the blood
on the floor and waits hoping it can
make him visible but he doesn't show up
as she moves to the other door he's
surprises her and grabs her from the
other side Sarah pours the last
remaining pack on him but he overpowers
her and mercilessly kills her on the
other hand Linda and Matthew find Frank
just as Carter passes away due to
excessive blood loss together they
return to the lab in search of Sarah
only to find her dead body after a while
as Frank is distracted Sebastian sneaks
up behind him and kills him with a metal
freaking crowbar he also injures Matthew
with it and locks both him and Linda in
the freezer panicked Linda manages to
close Matthew's wound using duct tape
she then tries to open the door of the
freezer but fails meanwhile Sebastian
prepares to make his Escape Gathering
materials to blow up the lab he mixes a
concoction and throws it like a grenade
to test it sometime later Linda creates
a magnet with the defibrillator which
allows her to finally open the door by
pulling the lever she gets Matthew out
and starts a fire to warm him up she
then grabs a flamethrower and begins
searching for Sebastian on the other
hand Sebastian sets up a bomb using the
concoction setting it to go off in five
minutes
dismay when he tries to escape in the
elevator Linda catches up to him and
sets him on fire Kevin's bacon got
roasted as Sebastian runs away Linda
activates the sprinkler system she hopes
that she can easily see him coming this
time but sadly Sebastian ambushes her
again he viciously attacks her and
attempts to choke her with his leg but
Matthew arrives in the nick of time and
knocks Sebastian's ass out the evil guy
gets right back up and attempts to swing
his crowbar at the duo however he
completely misses and ends up striking
the electric grid as a result he's fried
to a pulp pan fried believing that
Sebastian has died Linda and Matthew
start searching for the hidden bomb but
fail to find it soon the bomb detonates
but they manage to hide in a safe spot
the duo then tries to get out of the
building using an emergency ladder
through the left but when they begin
climbing Sebastian unexpectedly shows up
and grabs Linda by her leg in their
struggle they fall back onto the
elevator sending it back down despite
the grave injuries they keep on fighting
when all of a sudden the Pervert
Sebastian kisses taking advantage of
this distraction Linda grabs the cable
and releases the elevator because of
this Sebastian falls into the fire Char
grilled bacon while Linda climbs up to
safety the movie ends with Linda and
Matthew reuniting and walking out of the
building alive subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching